well this really bums me out but
podcaster Joe Rogan on Whose program
I've been a guest twice in the past has
unleashed the Jews Love Money
stereotype Trope call it whatever you
want which is linked to so much ugly
anti-Semitism now I'm gonna play the
clip and I'm going to talk about it I I
do want to say that I don't actually
think that Joe Rogan has a genuinely
anti-semitic bone or anti-semitic
ounce of lean muscle mass in his body I
think that he just doesn't understand
why saying Jews love money is different
than the example he gives of Italians
love eating pizza I just think he
doesn't get why
uh there are two different things and
it's a very bad analogy and as many of
you know I don't know if Rogan's willing
to have me back on his program you know
I've done some segments since I was last
on which were critical of things he said
but I think I've done them respectfully
and I would be glad to talk about any of
my views about his views anytime and I
would love to explain this to him as
well I have no idea
um but I don't think that this is about
Joe Rogan being an anti-semite
um just based on personally knowing him
let's get into the segment and hear how
it all went down
sitting next to Ilion Omar where she's
she's apologizing for talking about it's
all about the Benjamins yeah which is
just about money she's talking about she
shouldn't have apologized it's not an
anti-semitic statement I don't think
that is it's about Benjamins or money
you know the idea that Jewish people are
not into money is ridiculous listen it's
like saying Italians aren't into Pizza
stupid I understand okay
so listen
um the analogy to Italians eating pizza
couldn't be more misleading and it
couldn't be more wrong and there are a
number of important points here
first of all
analogizing to Republic to Republicans
liking Pizza to Italians liking Pizza
groups Jews liking money under a
category of what we might consider like
positive things and this is the
difficulty with some of these
anti-semitic tropes that in a vacuum
they sound like positive things you know
when people say Jews do so well in uh
the banking industry you might mean that
in a totally benign way or not but it's
connected to
long-standing conspiracies of Jewish
conspiracy to control certain industries
to their benefit into the detriment of
others and it's wrapped up in really
really ugly stuff so the analogy to it's
just a good thing liking money liking
Pizza it's just it's a it's a totally
fine and good thing that's that's one
issue which is it's connected to
all sorts of historical horrible stuff
that eating pizza by Italian people is
not secondly it's not Jews love money
and Italians love pizza right everyone
loves money Jews are the ones tagged
with the stereotype that they are so
obsessed with money above and beyond
everybody else that they conspire to
acquire it in a way that's different
than everybody else I mean have you met
black people who hate money have you met
white people who say oh money throw it
out put it in the trash burn it of
course not because it's not about liking
money ascribing it to Jews is about
something above and beyond that it's the
conspiracy to obtain money including by
immoral or illegal or deceptive means by
controlling certain industries and it's
different it's Unique in some way and
it's linked to thousands of years of
anti-Semitic Trope stereotypes and
discrimination now Rogan might genuinely
not know that
and so that's why I'm being careful and
saying I'm not alleging Joe Rogan is an
anti-semite in saying these things I
think he just doesn't understand or know
the reasons why this is very different
than Italians like pizza the last thing
about this is the analogy to Pizza is
also a terrible one because Italians
liking Pizza isn't a collective action
linked to anti-italian tropes and
stereotypes about Italian conspiracy to
like pizza or eat pizza like it doesn't
even make sense as I say it doesn't make
any sense you're talking about something
that is individual
when the discussion is about Jews liking
money it's no longer about individuals
right it's not about Jon Stewart likes
money he loves money
it's a trait that is ascribed to the
group working together and that's where
this entire like conspiracy stuff comes
from so uh I you know
it's really important
a lot of times when people say this
stuff they don't actually know or
understand the origins and they go I
don't know it's just like saying Jews
Like Love Money is is like saying black
people are good at basketball is like
saying whatever these sound like
positive things but they're interlaced
inextricably with really ugly historical
things
stereotyping xenophobia all sorts of
stuff and so it is really easy sometimes
for people to defend this sort of thing
and say liking money it's not even a bad
thing but it would be better if people
understood the history and really what
it was that that they were talking about
so again I I have no personal beef with
Rogan and whether or not I've been
blacklisted from his show I genuinely
have no idea but everything I've ever
said on this show about the things Joe
has said I'd be willing to talk about
with him I'm not hiding behind a
microphone or behind the screen or any
of it I don't know if he has any
interest in that but I I am glad to
anytime on his program or on mine you
might remember that a few years ago uh
the show got hacked and many thousands
of dollars were stolen we never got it
back it's a terrible feeling it can
happen to anyone but a couple of years
ago we got Aura which really gives us
significantly more peace of mind and our
sponsor Aura is the app that protects
you from scammers by alerting you
anytime your info like email passwords
social security number are found in data
breaches or also automatically requests
removal of your info from search engines
and it can reduce spam calls Aura alerts
you quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below